il y a plusieurs choses déjà
alors Pierre Palmade est sorti de
réanimation il est actuellement il a été
transféré dans un service de chirurgie
d'isible il est placé sous contrôle
psychologique puisque évidemment les
médecins ont peur qu'ils fassent une
tentative de suicide et là d'autres
examens ont été faits pour savoir si les
policiers vont pouvoir bientôt
l'entendre dans le dans le cadre d'une
garde à vue et s'il va pouvoir être
présenté devant le juge d'instruction
d'accord alors aujourd'hui il s'est
passé énormément de choses
déjà donc est sorti de réanimation les
victimes aujourd'hui
on sait que ça il y a eu pas une bonne
nouvelle
je pense que
vous verrez ça pire Palmade
la sœur de Pierre Palmade est sortie du
silence aussi à tenter et à tenter de
retranscrire l'état d'esprit de son
frère alors il y a le pouvoir à
l'hôpital alors
elle a dit où visiblement elle dit que
Pierre Palmade assumera effectivement
ses actes que il reconnaît sa
culpabilité qu'il va très mal il y a
quelqu'un qui a été le visiter qui dit
qui ne se souvient pas vraiment des
conditions spécifiques de l'accident
voilà c'est un peu embrouillé dans sa
tête ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les policiers attendent
vraiment pour l'entendre et la il
pourrait l'auditionner dès demain dès
demain mon frère Pierre à l'hôpital et
se réveille peu à peu à peu et réalise
l'horreur de ce qui s'est passé de ce
qu'il a causé il est catastrophique il a
honte l'idée d'avoir détruit la vie de
cette famille le dévast il prit et nous
avec lui pour que les victimes s'en
sortent avec le moins de séquelles
possible il prit vraiment il ne pense
qu'à eux il assumera toutes les
conséquences de ses actes avec la
conscience terrible qu'il ne pourra
jamais réparer le mal qu'il a fait aussi
vaincre cela puisse paraître pierre leur
demande pardon du plus profond de son
âme alors ça c'est la réaction donc de
Pierre Palmade via sa sœur et
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui encore dans la
nuit
l'alarme s'est déclenchée chez Pierre
Palmade c'est ça autour du beurre 30 du
matin voilà donc il y a une intrusion il
y a une intrusion dans la nuit d'hier
chez Pierre Palmade il a en fait donc
son corps de ferme ça à peu près c'est
3500 m² de terrain sur place il y a donc
un corps de une maison de plus de
presque 400 mètres carrés et puis il y a
une petite dépendance à studio de 40
mètres carrés qui a été habilité en en
bureau et visiblement ce serait ce tu ce
studio qui aurait été cambriolé pour
l'instant on ne sait pas si des objets
manquent mais c'est c'est c'est ce
studio là où des gens serait ce serait
comment dire et pourquoi on sait
pourquoi alors on ne sait pas pourquoi
ce qu'on sait c'est que des les deux
personnes qui ont fui l'accident
seraient revenu dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche
pour récupérer les valises en fait il y
a des vides des femmes la légendaires
sont en train d'analyser les caméras de
vidéosurveillance puisque des témoins
les auraient vu en fait en train de
repartir avec leurs affaires d'accord
donc ils ne se sont toujours pas rendus
à ces deux passagers une vingtaine
d'années qui se serait enfuis du
véhicule de Pierre Palmade lors de
l'accident aujourd'hui encore comme on
dit il y a eu aussi autre chose hier
soir un homme de 47 ans a contacté les
policiers en affirmant être l'un des
passagers de la voiture de Pierre
Palmade alors c'est voilà il s'est rendu
à la police c'est un homme de 47 ans il
est arrivé très alcoolisé sur place il a
été placé en garde à vue et à la suite
de cette garde à vue les les policiers
se sont rendus compte ben voilà que
c'est un SDF qui était déjà connu des
forces de l'or de l'ordre et que en fait
il avait menti c'est un pari qu'il a
fait qu'il a fait avec un copain à lui
voilà d'aller se dénoncer mais il est
rien dans cette histoire
extrêmement surveillé beaucoup craignent
qui mettent fin à ses jours alors c'est
logiquement il est très fragile
effectivement il est très fragile
psychologique quand je dis pas ça du
tout pour le dédouaner ce qu'il a fait
mais c'est vrai que il est très
surveillé le témoignage de sa sœur fait
que on a l'impression qu'il prend
conscience de ce qu'il a fait mais pour
le moment c'est vrai que c'est un
premier pas et mettre basic nous dira si
ça satisfait les les victimes et
probablement pas alors justement on va
parler des victimes d'ailleurs comment
quels sont les nouvelles moi de bâti
vous êtes l'avocat de la famille des
victimes de l'accident on en est où
aujourd'hui les nouvelles elles sont pas
bonnes Siri d'abord on a une passagère
qui a perdu son bébé elle était censée à
coucher le 14 mai d'un enfant d'une
petite fille et aujourd'hui cet enfant a
perdu la vie à la suite de cet accident
je sais alors on entend diverses
versions là-dessus quelle est la version
réelle parce qu'on entend plein de
choses alors la dernière version selon
les éléments avant expertisé autopsie
c'est que ce bébé serait né et aurait
respiré à partir du moment où il a
respiré qu'il est né viable ça devient
si je puis dire je prends un être humain
au sens pénal par moral mais pénal donc
c'est très important pour la faire parce
que Pierre pamade pourrait être
poursuivi pour homicide involontaire
après la mort de ce bébé voilà c'est ça
maître bête tout à fait c'est ça il va y
avoir un enjeu de juridique de
qualification juridique comment comment
parce que pour éviter les spectateur
c'est assez intéressant comment on peut
savoir voilà ce qui s'est réellement
passé et comment pour savoir si le bébé
restera pas parce que c'est vrai que
dans cette affaire c'est quand même un
élément prépondérant sur ça c'est
extrêmement simple il va y avoir d'abord
une autopsie qui va être réalisée sur
sur le bébé c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement dur et douloureux pour les
familles évidemment ils imaginaient le
14 mai célébrer la naissance de cette
petite fille qui a été choyé par ses
parents qui étaient attendus plus que
tout dans ce dans ce foyer qui attendait
ce premier enfant comme comme on attend
un événement heureux et donc là ils vont
devoir être confrontés dans les
prochaines heures à une autopsie du bébé
et donc c'est cette autopsie qui va dire
de façon formelle et définitive si
effectivement le bébé est né viable et
donc effectivement de deux choses l'une
soit le bébé n'est pas néviable
l'autopsie et les expertises nous diront
que le bébé n'est pas névable auquel cas
effectivement il y a la jurisprudence de
2001 qui s'applique et l'infraction de
de de domicile involontaire ne veut pas
être tenu ou alors comme je le pense
comme on le pense comme les éléments
qui nous reviennent semblent le
démontrer l'enfant est né viable et donc
par conséquent il y aurait la
qualification de homicide involontaire
qui pourrait être retenu contre Monsieur
Palmade auquel cas il en courrait une
peine de 10 ans d'emprisonnement non et
dans le premier cas ce serait combien
d'emprisonnement et donc dans le premier
cas ce serait soit 5 ans soit 7 ans
d'accord des blessures involontaires là
ça pourrait
parce que on a tout un tas de de
circonstances aggravantes la première
circonstance aggravante c'est évidemment
d'avoir conduit sous l'empire de
substances illicites on parle de cocaïne
aujourd'hui dans tous les médias mais
encore une fois il va y avoir des
expertises sur sur ce point-là et on
sait pas s'il y a pas d'autres éléments
s'il y a pas des cocktails en plus de la
cocaïne est-ce qu'il y a eu de l'alcool
est-ce qu'il y a eu d'autres drogues
est-ce que il y a eu du cannabis et donc
tout ça ce sont des circonstances
aggravantes et puis il y a les
infractions au code de la route est-ce
qu'il était en excès de vitesse est-ce
que il a manqué à d'autres obligations
qui relèvent du code de la route tout ça
ce sont des circonstances aggravantes
qui vont appliquer sa responsabilité
morale évidemment ça va sans dire mais
surtout pénal alors là donc c'est la
c'est la première mauvaise nouvelle la
maman
elle est dans quel état la maman elle
est dévastée physiquement d'abord elle
est dévastée physiquement elle a perdu
son bébé encore une fois elle
s'attendait à dans les prochaines
semaines mettre au monde une petite
fille qu'elle chérit plus que tout
qu'elle aime plus que tout avec son
compagnon son mari c'était vraiment faut
imaginer un petit foyer d'amour un petit
cocon d'amour c'était leur premier
enfant leur première fille ils étaient
en train d'acheter les vêtements les
jouets préparer la venue de cet enfant
et là dans les prochaines heures il va
être confronté à une autopsie autant
vous dire que
c'est extrêmement difficile mais en plus
de ça elle est dévastée d'un point de
vue physique puisqu'elle a des vertèbres
abîmées une entorse de cou des côtes
fêlés enfin elle est dans un état
pitoyable et désastreux physiquement et
puis pour les autres c'est encore pire
parce que le conducteur il a été broyé
entre le volant et et le fauteuil et le
gamin à l'arrière qui a 6 ans qui est le
fils du conducteur il est d'après les
dires de sa mère
défiguré vous voulez avoir des nouvelles
de ces garçons ce qui est un garçon de 6
ans dans le véhicule lui les nouvelles
sont pas bonnes non plus nouvelle sont
pas bonnes moi aux dernières nouvelles
j'essaye d'être le plus en contact
possible avec avec mes clients
concernant le conducteur donc cet homme
de 38 ans qui est un homme adorable qui
est un homme adorable il faut le dire si
vous voulez faut imaginer qu'il monte
dans ce véhicule pour accompagner sa
belle-sœur et quelle heure déjà chez
elle il était entre 18 et 19h on était
vendredi dernier et il va avoir des
attentions toutes particulières pour
cette femme enceinte il va lui demander
c'est ça on aimerait que ça va le
contexte parce qu'on se met à la place
de cette famille qu'est-ce qui se passe
donc ils sont en famille ils sont en
famille il y a cette dame qui est
enceinte qui vient visiter sa
belle-famille et donc il est 19h elle va
rentrer chez elle son beau-frère va lui
proposer de la raccompagner il va
prendre son fils de 6 ans avec lui pour
accompagner sa belle-sœur et dès lors
qu'il monte dans le véhicule il va avoir
des attentions toutes particulières il
va lui demander si la température lui
convient il va lui demander si l'allure
lui convient alors qu'il est
parfaitement dans les clous du code de
la route il va lui proposer deux chemins
deux itinéraires en lui proposant un
itinéraire un peu plus long mais pour
éviter les dos d'âne vous voyez on était
dans quelque chose de très attentionné
il faut imaginer cette famille c'était
un nid de douceur et les personnes qui
la composent sont vraiment tous plus
bienveillant les uns que les autres et
donc ils vont être confrontés à ce drame
à l'horreur et à l'irrémédiable et puis
vous savez pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée sur la bonté de ces gens-là quand
j'ai la passagère au téléphone ce matin
ses premiers mots ont été pour remercier
pour remercier la passante qui est venue
et qui lui a tenu la tête le temps que
les pompiers arrivent et qui fera en
sorte qu'elles ne tombent pas
inconsciente elles ne tombent pas dans
les vapes et puis après elle va
remercier les pompiers elle va remercier
la France entière du soutien inestimable
qu'elle a reçu en allumant son téléphone
ce matin elle se souvient de tout alors
elle se souvient pas de tout elle a elle
a des trous noirs il y a eu des moments
où elle a évidemment des choses qu'elle
ne peut pas retracer et là si vous
voulez trois étapes dont elles se
souvient très fortement la première
étape c'est le véhicule fou qui vient en
face avec les phares dans les yeux ça
s'en souvient très bien d'accord la
deuxième chose elle se souvient la
deuxième image c'est l'accident une fois
qu'il a été réalisé elle se souvient
voir le conducteur compressé entre le
volant et le fauteuil et essayer de
s'extirper du véhicule elle va essayer
par un instinct maternel qu'elle allait
très prochainement avoir aller en
direction du gamin qui est à l'arrière
du véhicule sur la banquette arrière
mais elle a pas assez de force elle sort
du véhicule elle s'extirent par la porte
passager et là manquant de force elle va
s'effondrer sur place et elle va tout de
suite mettre les mains sur son ventre et
hurler mon bébé mon bébé ayant
conscience qu'il se passe quelque chose
intérieurement elle elle est elle a su à
quel moment que c'était quelqu'un qui
était connu qui avait commis cet
accident alors si vous voulez ce sont
des gens et je les dis qui cherche tout
sauf la lumière qui sont dans qui
cherchent l'anonymat le plus complet et
je réitère leur demande ce soir qu'aucun
média n'aille devant l'hôpital une salle
qui ne cherchent pas à trouver
l'identité de ses victimes parce que ça
va être très dur pour eux de se
reconstruire et ils veulent pouvoir se
reconstruire sans qu'on connaisse leur
nom leur prénom leur visage et ça c'est
une demande qui m'a été faite et qui est
très importante mais évidemment il ne
savait pas tout ça il ne savait pas le
connaît ils connaissent le pire pas loin
alors certains de la famille
connaissaient pierre Palma d'autres ne
le connaissaient pas du tout et
évidemment leur crainte aujourd'hui
c'est que la notoriété de Monsieur
Palmade biaise le traitement médiatique
ou très biaise le traitement judiciaire
je les ai évidemment rassuré sur ce
point ça va pas être le contraire plutôt
alors je sais pas si c'est le contraire
en toute état de cause qui est sûr c'est
que nul n'est au dessus de la loi c'est
ça et que du côté des participes et
l'avocat que je suis sera très attentif
au traitement qui sera qui sera accordé
à ce monsieur et en faisant en sorte que
la loi soit appliquée strictement
appliquée une question importante un
qu'on se pose tous aujourd'hui il y a eu
des excuses de la part de Pierre Palmade
par l'intermédiaire de de sa sœur est-ce
qu'ils ont pris connaissance de ces
excuses la famille alors pas tous parce
qu'il y a déjà deux membres qui sont
encore en réanimation le conducteur et
son fils qui sont encore en réanimation
d'ailleurs le papa est dans le
conducteur il est dans quel état là il
est très mal en 72 heures je crois qu'il
en est à 5 ou 7 opérations c'est ça donc
il est brisé il est brisé dans sa chair
il est brisé dans ses eaux et j'imagine
l'accident était d'une violence extrême
l'accident c'est on l'imagine tous on le
visualise tous c'est une voiture à
combien alors ça on n'a pas encore c'est
on n'a pas encore ces indications là ce
qu'on sait c'est que c'est un véhicule
fou avec une
volonté mortifère qui est rentrée dans
le véhicule de mes clients qui pour le
coup roulait tout à fait paisiblement
aujourd'hui ils sont tous marqués dans
leur chair marqué dans leur corps qui
ont pris connaissance des excuses voilà
on va aller ceux qui ont pris
connaissance des astuces ils disent quoi
aujourd'hui ils disent quoi des excuses
de sur des excuses je le dis très
clairement
et je crois qu'il faut être très clair
et très ferme sur ce point là il y a
qu'une victime dans ce dossier ce sont
ceux qui ont vécu cet accident
dramatique et mortifère vous avez raison
de le dire ça c'est très important de je
pense de remettre un peu une victime ce
sont les sets cette famille il y a
qu'une victime c'est cette famille c'est
important de le dire c'est important de
remettre l'église au milieu du village
et les excuses elles valent ce qu'elle
valent c'est-à-dire que d'abord elles
sont énoncées par le truchement de la
soeur et puis par ailleurs les excuses
vous imaginez bien qu'elle ne répare en
rien
qui avait qui avait une vie devant lui
cette petite fille qui allait voir le
jour qui allait avoir une vie heureuse
avec des parents heureux avec qui était
le fruit d'une union d'amour c'est
important de le dire l'enfant de 6 ans
qui était dans le véhicule défiguré
ce que je sais aujourd'hui c'est que il
a la mâchoire complètement détruite et
que vraisemblablement visuellement c'est
plus tout à fait le même donc voilà ça
va être très compliqué pour cet enfant
de se reconstruire pour se conducteur ce
papa de se reconstruire si tenter qu'il
s'en sortent pour cette maman qui a
perdu un enfant de se reconstruire et
puis ça c'est le premier cercle
concentrique si on va sur le second
troisième cercle il y a évidemment le le
frère de du petit garçon qui a 8 ans qui
aujourd'hui à son papa qui est en
hospitalisé qui en réanimation qui a son
petit frère qui est hospitalisé qui en
réanimation de l'autre côté on a une mer
qui vient de perdre son enfant une
future mère qui vient de perdre son
enfant on a un papa qui est éploré un
futur papa qui est pleurer vous voyez
les dommages collatéraux ils sont
infinis ils sont dantesques vous êtes
donc on l'a compris si vous ne rejoignez
à 21h05 vous êtes l'avocat de la famille
des victimes de cette de ce terrible
accédant accident votre objectif c'est
que Pierre Palmade il soit déféré
rapidement alors l'objectif c'est
évidemment qu'il soit placé en pas vu
qui soit déférés qui est un magistrat
instructeur et qui soit saisi qui est un
juge des libertés de tension qui se
prononce sur sa future détention
provisoires et que infinie à terme la
famille puisse avoir justice alors
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire avoir justice
quand on a perdu un bébé de 6 ou 7 mois
dans son ventre c'est un vœu pieux
alors je vous dis tout j'ai entendu des
gens dire il va falloir qu'ils payent
qu'il paye des millions pour ce qu'il a
fait oui mais il pourrait payer des
milliards ça rachètera pas ce bébé qui
est perdu et j'ai eu la maman la future
maman celle qui allait être la future
maman au téléphone elle vous pourriez
lui proposer le soleil dans la main
gauche et la Lune dans la main droite ça
rachèterait en rien son enfant elle
c'était le fruit d'une belle union faut
voir ce couple ce mari se perd d'une
dignité incroyable et aujourd'hui ils
ont tout perdu ils sont effondrés est-ce
qu'ils ont alors oui Myriam il paraît
que la voiture de Pierre Palmade n'était
pas assurée est-ce que vous en savez
plus
on n'a pas encore toutes ces
informations on n'a pas encore accès à
toutes les pièces de la procédure qu'on
sait aujourd'hui c'est qu'évidemment de
manière un peu multifactorielle on sait
que ça a conduit à ce chaos et à cette
voiture dramatique mais on sait pas
encore l'histoire d'assurance la vitesse
aura des expertises il y aura des
analyses sur tout ça et évidemment nous
on y sera très attentif ah oui j'ai une
oui maître vous parliez de la future
détention provisoire ça c'est la
question aussi une fois qu'il aura été
entendu pierre palmat peut-être mis en
examen on verra il y a deux possibilités
soit il est sous contrôle judiciaire
avec par exemple qui rentre chez lui
voilà avec obligation de soin soit il
est placé en détention provisoire et
pour le moment c'est vrai qu'il y a une
petite musique qui dit peut-être
contrôle judiciaire est-ce que ça ça
choquerait la famille et l'avocat que
vous êtes alors évidemment ça je le dis
sans détour et de manière très directe
ça choquerait évidemment la famille ce
serait à mon avis probablement un
contre-sens ou c'est quelque chose
d'assez contre-intuitif dans la mesure
où la détention provisoire elle est
régie par les critères de l'article 144
et ces critères de l'article 144 sont
rentrés dans de la procédure trop
technique ils expliquent que la
détention provisoire elle est justifiée
dès lors qu'il y a un risque de
concertation frauduleuse dès lors qu'il
y a un risque de déperdition d'épreuve
dès lors qu'il y a un risque de trouble
à l'ordre public si je prends le risque
de troubles à l'ordre public vous
imaginez bien que la réaction de la
famille qui est aujourd'hui éplorée et
qui a confiance en institution
judiciaire et bien évidemment ce serait
pas tout à fait la même réaction s'il
était remis en liberté et puis il y a
quand même et je le dis deux individus
qui étaient là au moment des faits qui
ont pris la fuite qui ont rajouté à cet
acte absolument odieux et ignominieux de
la lâcheté c'est ça puisqu'ils étaient
dans le véhicule et que au-delà de la
non-assistance à personne en danger qui
peut être qualifié juridiquement et
pénalement il y a aussi un manquement
moral que je ne peux même pas qualifier
qui ont fait que ces deux individus ont
pris la fuite on parle aujourd'hui d'un
cambriolage d'un thématique cambriolage
qui aurait eu lieu hier moi je sais pas
si c'est un cambriolage je sais pas si
c'est pas ces deux individus qui sont
pas revenus sur les lieux pour nettoyer
l'appartement je sais pas s'ils ont pas
nettoyer la voiture avant de partir et
je suis et surtout pas si Pierre Palmas
si Monsieur Palma était remis en liberté
s'il y aurait pas le risque d'une
concertation frauduleuse entre les deux
individus qui parlent l'acheter encore
une fois ne sont pas là ne se sont pas
rendus au service de police et qui
pourraient tout à fait s'accorder sur
une version et pourquoi pas même dire
que c'est pas Pierre Palmade qui qui
conduisait ou que toutefois c'est l'un
des deux qui a mis un coup de vent vous
voyez je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut
figer la procédure il faut permettre au
juge d'instruction il faut permettre aux
magistrats instructeur de poursuivre son
instruction de façon tout à fait sereine
et dans les meilleures conditions et il
me semble et l'expérience qui est la
mienne me fait dire que dans ces
conditions-là autant du point de vue des
critères de l'article 144 que d'un point
de vue factuel la détention provisoire
se justifie à mes yeux mais c'est
évidemment le votre instructeur qui à
mon avis en fin de semaine avec le juge
des libertés de la détention qui prendra
la décision
j'ai pas connaissance de l'avocat
derrière
l'usagés ainsi que des objets sexuels
ont été retrouvés dans la dans la maison
de Pierre Palmade donc ça c'est quelque
chose dont vous pourrez éventuellement
vous servir et puis et puis
aussi le il y a des liquides en fait qui
sont en cours d'analyse pour savoir quel
type de drogue a été utilisé pendant
cette fameuse soirée Kep sexe alors ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre et c'est ce
que la famille voilà il y a le téléphone
aussi le fameux téléphone qu'on croyait
avoir disparu qui a été retrouvé en fait
il avait été pris par les gendarmes dans
une autre procédure et du coup il est
actuellement en cours d'analyse par par
les forces de l'ordre non mais vous
voyez bien que l'absurdité de ce dossier
c'est que on a même pas
l'excuse de l'insouciance de la jeunesse
c'est à dire que on peut imaginer qu'on
soit jeune et qu'on fasse n'importe quoi
qu'on prenne des drogues mais voilà non
mais c'est déjà c'est déjà pas
concevable mais encore moins encore
moins quand on a encore moins quand on a
cet âge là encore moins quand on a
l'expérience de la vie il y a tout à
fait quand on prend des drogues sauf de
prendre le volant de prendre son
véhicule de foncer tout droit mais
au-delà de ça on prend on prend des
drogues on se fout en l'air tout seul on
va chez soi et puis on reste chez soi on
se fait soigner on se fait traiter mais
on prend pas un véhicule pour commencer
pas de drogue du tout vous amuserez tout
autant regarder pour vous pour vous ces
personnes sont c'est que c'est quoi pour
vous les ont considérer comme des
meurtriers aujourd'hui de toute façon
c'est l'information judiciaire qui va le
déterminer moralement on peut avoir un
jugement très dur et je crois que
l'ensemble des Français de ce que j'ai
vu et ça a beaucoup touché mes clients
ont un jugement juste un jugement dur
mais un jugement juste sur ce qui ne
s'est passé après la qualification
pénale ça va être une la discussion ça
va être un combat pendant 18-24 mois
évidemment pour pour ça mon cabinet sera
très attentif